i think
it's
still probably preparation
i
like to prepare always but also in these
events you have a little time um
and you also have to rest as well
because they're intense but like i think
i do pretty good job in a short amount
of time
in terms of prep and i don't use much
help of seconds so i'm like
much more kind of in sync with my own
prep just and also i try to work on my
sharpness try not to blunder things but
i wouldn't say it's my strength yet but
i'm hoping to eventually become a guy
who just never blunders
i think my biggest weakness is maybe my
lack of confidence sometimes
you know if i lose one and a half game i
already think uh
you know that that's the end of the
world is near uh and i should become a
full-time adjustable author instead
you know you see me sometimes in a
platform having long streaks of not
winning games you know not being able to
convert things because uh
yeah i like a bit of that uh killer
instinct when when not in form but when
things go my way then it all comes back
together
uh neither my heart opening is neither
for sure
i think i've caught up quite a bit
in rapid
templates online and this year with so
many online events once again for me
next to the champions tour also i'll be
playing some other online events
so i will really try to keep that as one
of the main focuses for this year it
doesn't matter for me how it's called
you know the champion store or not the
championship but if the if the champions
are there
then i'm i'm really eager to fight